there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people the Avengers
is really the culmination of a few films
that have come before that really set up
the story so it's bringing together
Captain America Thor
you know Black Widow Hulk Hawkeye Nick
Fury as part of it Agent Coulson as part
of it
films are so huge now and have so many
shots usually one house can take on
everything we had Iron Man from the
previous film you know we'd built on
kind of what we developed for the first
two films and you know what was great
about this one was he had a brand new
suit his brand new ways to put it on and
take it off that were really fun to come
up with but he's the hard surface
creature you don't see his eyes and so
when we started bidding the work that
character we really wanted to do with a
lot of it was working with mark you know
we set out from the beginning and knew
that we needed to have an actor do this
performance and he and Joss would talk a
lot about anger and you know what type
of anger is this Hulk and a lot of it
came from how Mark was playing Bruce
Banner you know that kind of world-weary
kind of tired accepting of the fact that
you know he's got this The Hulk inside
of him and that's that's part of who he
is we did photo shoots where we shot
basically everything you know the area
between his fingers he like opened his
mouth was shot his gums and his teeth
and you know the corners of his eyes
everything we could find to make sure
that Hulk was based on him but on top of
that we also did a life cast life cast
is a molding process where we can
actually put a plaster and they use a
lot of very high-tech materials to do it
now but we take our CG mark and we take
the life cast scan and we kind of clone
over the really high-frequency detail I
mean one of the great things that Joss
did right from the beginning was say
Mark Ruffalo should be part of the
design which was new because the last
two films you didn't see as much of the
actor in the Hulk design and so by
incorporating mark and
you know we added the same sort of
little bits of grey and the temples of
Hulk's hair that Mark Ruffalo has all
these things that you know we don't
typically do but it really lend a lot of
credibility to the character because in
the end I think that decision to really
look at Mark Ruffalo and trying to
incorporate everything we could from him
made a big difference
probably our other big challenge on the
film in that the whole last third of the
movie is generally said in New York but
we were only shot there first three or
four days of principal photography so
the rest of New York if we're if you're
flying around or it's an aerial shot or
we're down on Park Avenue viaduct like
in the trailer there's that shot where
he circles around all the Avengers that
whole area was shot on a green-screen
in New Mexico and the way we did it was
we had a team of four guys go out to New
York and they spent eight weeks shooting
they're kind of like you know Google
Streetview you have those spheres you
can look around it's it's like a super
high resolution version of that and it's
the same idea like every hundred feet
our show we would shoot another super
high resolution fix fear of photography
and then we had lidar go in and scan all
the buildings so we had geometry to
start with and we had all this
photography and we'd project the
photography onto the buildings and
that's how we'd make our background
plates and then on the street level we
had to get rid of all the cars people
dressing everything put back in streets
and then dress it out so we we ended up
building taxi cabs cop cars trees
sandwich boards you know construction
equipment and everything we found in New
York we would we would sort of build to
dress out those backgrounds I mean our
goal in the end was to make it feel like
you couldn't tell that you know wasn't
an entirely shot in New York it's
extremely complicated and time-consuming
to try and do everything in CG so we we
certainly film everything that's real
that we can and I think the best effects
work always you know has you know some
some component of reality to kind of
hinge everything around even if it's the
photography we use rather than building
an entirely CG New York haven't starting
from all that photography really gave us
something to kind of
Anker the shots around and I think that
makes a big difference with that sort of
focus in mind and the goal for each
project you really can take on any kind
of things you want to create